Unfortunately, I'm going to have to start radiation and chemo treatments.
Can you recommend some tips to help minimize the side effects?
Also, it is recommended to increase your protein intake during treatments.
So if so, are there any specific protein types that you'd recommend?
And if so, is one with way or college and okay?
Or what if they have based protein be better?
If you're going to take protein powder, we recommend that you use the U.S. enzymes brand protein enzyme.
And the reason why we have chosen that for cancer patients is because of the low content of glutamate and the thyroid unit.
Which can be a theater of cancer, but this has a very low content of that.
It's also completely clear-based. It does not use way.
So there's no possibility of any dairy drivers in it.
So it comes in vanilla or it comes in chocolate.
So you're going to add this to a shake with berries.
I highly suggest vanilla.
Otherwise, the chocolate is quite tasty.
As far as a protocol for doing chemo and radiation, we do have a protocol to support those doing chemo.
You can find it on our blog post.
I think it's on the member site as well.
We're talking three to 24 hour fast prior to doing chemo.
And then we should not take a lot of.
We're talking about anti-oxidants for at least that 48 hour window after the administration of the chemo.
So I assume this person's talking about a chemotherapy IV.
So that's what we're talking about that 48 hour window.
So the idea is that chemotherapy is oxidizing the agent.
And taking it oxidizing the agent.
It's basically a poison that sort of oxidizing agent is.
So if you're taking an antioxidant, which you know, everybody's trying to get antioxidant.
Why?
Because chemicals like toxins and pesticides and herbicides are oxidizing agents.
They're poisons.
That's how they kill little bugs because they're poisons.
And that's what they do to your body.
And that's what they can do to a cell.
Why they're dangerous oxidizing agents will.
Can be cancer causing them.
So that's why we would take antioxidants.
So you take, you know, fresh fruits and vegetables have a lot of antioxidants in them.
So you're taking it to accidents by E correctly.
But there are antioxidant nutrients might have been see would be considered an antioxidant.
And if they have acid, it would be considered an antioxidant.
Would it yield and would it yield precursors or be considered antioxidants?
Well, that's why I had an oncologist will say I don't let's take it any supplements.
We're going to do chemo.
Well, but they really need is they don't let's take it into antioxidants.
Because if you're going to do chemo, oxidizing agent, you don't want to negate the effects of the chemo.
But not leave chemo just because it's poison and just say you don't want to be taking an antioxidant while the chemo is trying to work.
So you lay off of those, you know, nutrients that are highly antioxidative in their nature.
So you wouldn't take vitamin C.
You wouldn't take curcumin.
You wouldn't take out from a peg acid.
You wouldn't take the file.
448 hours post chemo.
So it's going to do chemo IV at 9 o'clock Monday morning at last, tell dude.
So I would wait till noon on Wednesday before I take those types of supplements in the chemo protocol.
That's in our blog.
We also caution against taking.
Things that will really push the detoxication pathway because that's another argument that a oncologist would say is that I don't want to take it as much.
Support for phase one and phase two detox of the liver because we're going to put this chemo in you and you're just going to detoxify it.
You know, well, hopefully you're going to detoxify it, but they don't want you to detoxify it.
While it's really doing its work and there's a lot of talk about out there for years, the chemo really does its work on the cancer of the first 48 hours.
That's why we say 48 hours.
So you don't do, you know, you maybe even lay back off of your liver support products for 48 hours.
Then you do it again, you know, at my example, at noon on Wednesday, you take those liver support products again.
So then doing at 24 or even 48 hour fast prior to doing chemo can be extremely helpful.
We have had numerous patients that have done that and said it really helped minimize the sign effects.
We have a radiation homeopath for radiation that's this right there.
Nothing is going to be perfect to pull out radiation.
This is just a homeopath.